le grand jour est arrivé pour dylan
après des mois d'entraînement le magnet
quoi passe le concours du meilleur
apprenti départementales et régionales
nous le retrouvons pour sa troisième et
dernière épreuve la coiffure de soirée
le jeune coiffeur et laura son modèle se
met en place et déjà les consignes sont
lancés dylan concentrés écoutent à peine
et prépare son matériel un regard sur la
montre et le top départ est lancé
c'est parti pour 50 minutes de création
capillaire ses deux premières épreuves
la mise en plis techniques et la couleur
se sont plutôt bien déroulées au matin
alors dylan et serein pas stressé
justement elle a l'air plutôt confiant
ambiance studieuse dans la salle tous
les concurrents se concentrent sur leurs
coiffures dylan mis sur le volume dans
cette épreuve
mais les cheveux de laura lui joue des
tours ils n'arrivent pas à les plaques
et convenablement un coup de brosse par
ci un coup de peigne par là le jeune
apprenti tente de rattraper le coup
finalement avant même la fin de
l'épreuve il range ses affaires sans
cacher sa déception
il ya des choses qui vont pas quand mais
maintenant populaire pendant tout à fait
dans la salle d'accueil la honte a reçu
ce matin
place maintenant à la notation les jurys
étudie chaque coiffure ici on juge la
technique mais surtout la créativité et
l'esthétique avec un système de points
au final
il pourra donc y avoir plusieurs
meilleurs apprentis un certain nombre de
points donne la médaille de bronze puis
l'argent et enfin l'or et avec cette
médaille d'or régionale la qualification
pour la finale nationale
pendant que dylan attend les
délibérations en famille
on a tenté de savoir si sa prestation
avait été à la hauteur
un quart sont prometteurs
là des idées maintenant sur le plan
technique que c'est normal il n'a qu'un
an et demi de profession donc un an et
demi de l'apprentissage
mais s'il continue dans cette voie là ça
sera bien cette longue journée touche à
sa fin et avec elle le verdict tant
attendu les premiers appelés ont obtenu
la médaille départementale de bronze
mais le temps passe et dylan n'y croit
mais quelques minutes plus tard
pour
région dylan a décroché la médaille d'or
départementale et la médaille d'argent
régionale
une belle récompense je m'attendais pas
à ça parce que je pensais pas être reçus
ils terminent quatrièmes ex-aequo sur 20
pour sa famille c'est la consécration
d'un gros investissement
je suis très fier de lui quoi très
content parce que va tous tout ce qu'il
a fait ça a payé quoi c'est qui comme il
il a la passion de sabin je crois la
suis très content de pause